we began with the deadly flash flood at
a popular Arizona swimming area a
weekend storm unleashed a massive wall
of water that slammed into a group of
people escaping the heat in a creek the
flood surprised swimmers and swept some
away nine people were killed including
six children bodies were found as far as
two miles downriver one person a 27 year
old man is still missing more dangerous
weather and possible flooding is
forecast for today Mireya Villarreal is
in Payson Arizona northeast of Phoenix
cell phone video captures flash flooding
as it tore through central Arizona on
Saturday officials estimate more than a
hundred people were at a popular
swimming hole as the wall of water and
debris came barreling down Ellison Creek
and the East Verde River holy mackerel
footage shot by DISA Alexander shows one
man in a tree above the rapids clinging
to a young child there's the son over
there and the mom in the water 14 family
members were reportedly celebrating a
birthday there nine bodies were
recovered the youngest of them just two
years old rescuers airlifted four
stranded family members to safety one
woman says she's desperate for
information on her missing brother one
witness said all they heard was this
tremendous roar Ron Saddle Meyer is the
local fire chief and says Saturday's
thunderstorm intensified over a remote
area scorched by last month's High Line
fire and all that debris and ash and
everything came roaring down that
that drainage and caught those people
totally by surprise
thick soot and mud have only made it
more difficult for some 40 people
searching at least five miles of rocky
and rural terrain we are taking our time
and there's a lot of debris piles that
we're trying to you know check through
and make sure that there's nobody in
there such a tragedy for that community
that was Maria via we're all reporting
from Arizona where more thunderstorms
are forecast today